hi my name is Samuel Leeds and in this
video I'm going to do something
absolutely crazy that I don't see any
other property investors on do in this
video I'm going to expose and reveal my
2018 property investors business plan it
means that you will get to see exactly
what I am planning and strategizing to
buy myself
now a lot of people would take thousands
of pounds to have this information and
you might be thinking are you crazy why
would you reveal your business plan
people have tried to tell me not to do
this I'm close friends of mine saying
don't do it if you reveal your property
investing business plan everyone is
going to copy you this you will create
competition for yourself you will push
the property prices up and what's the
point so let me explain firstly my
reasoning for doing this the most
successful businesses in the world
reveal their business plan to the world
let's take McDonald's McDonald's is one
of the largest businesses in the world
believe it or not to know what they make
most of their money on property
investing that's how they make their
money and their business plan McDonald's
is reveal online for the world to see
Book of Ezekiel says write down the
vision make it plain so that all can see
why why do that well I believe that when
you speak it out write down so the
organs they suddenly it just begins to
happen easier so most property investors
are pretty secretive about their
businesses they keep their cards close
to their chest I am NOT gonna do that in
this video so stay tuned and you're
gonna get to see exactly what my
business plan is for property investing
in 2008 it
[Music]
so in 2018 I am going to buy 10 houses
in total
two of those houses are going to be
lease option agreements that I'll be
keeping for myself a lease option
agreement is a property where you buy
now pay later so you fixed the price now
and you pay for it later I believe that
right now we're having a massive
expansion and property prices are on the
rise lease option agreements are no
money down deals and in the time where
you are waiting for completion you will
benefit from all the rent and all the
capital appreciation regardless of not
putting any money down upfront lease
option agreement are something that I've
been doing for almost a decade and if
you've been to my property investors
crash course or even just read my book
you'll see it's something that I've been
teaching openly to people for probably
about five years now
two of my properties are going to be
straightforward by low rent hi HMOs HMO
standing for house of multiple occupancy
where you rent the property out on a
room-by-room
basis again this is something that I've
been teaching at my property investors
crash course it's also in my book for
quite some time and I've been doing
successfully for almost a decade the
five rules for HMOs and certainly for
the way I'm going to be doing it with
these two is going to be one make sure
that it's close to a city center I'm
going to be buying two HMOs in
Middlesbrough two it needs to be in good
condition because if you're going to be
having to do a refurb then that could be
a deposit on another house the bank will
not lend you money to do the property so
this has been good condition three it
needs to be in an area where by there's
a Power Team and an HMO manager four you
need to have a minimum of four letter
book rooms and five you should never pay
more than twenty five thousand pounds
per letter more room so if there's five
bedrooms you shouldn't pay more than 125
thousand pounds for the HML the other
six deals are a little bit more
interesting
buy and refinance when I started out
property investing in fact the first
house that I ever bought I bought it 25%
below market value and then I refinance
their back up to his true value that
same day now this was in 2008 2009 where
the recession was just about to hit the
country hard and what happened when the
recession came is they changed the rules
they said you can no longer bind with
finance the same day you've got to wait
six months which was the first problem
the second problem was when you waited
six months the value would come they
would undervalue it so you wouldn't be
able to pull your money out at all and
the reason that was happening was
because the recession is on the way
things are beginning to get a bit easier
in this area now and things are
beginning to shift so because house
prices are going up considerably and
lenders are lack sudden they have been
previously as well in a lot of areas my
plan is to buy a cheap HMO property it
won't be a current HMO it would just be
a big derelict property and to can't buy
it for cash I'll then spend six months
doing it up renovating it into a nice
big professional house of multiple
occupancy after six months I will then
refinance the property and I will pull
out all of the money that I put in and
potentially even some of the refurb
costs as well meaning it will be left
with a very little money down deal and
of course I'll be you then generating a
high rental income from it as well now
this type of deal always comes with its
risks because whenever you're expecting
Builders to stick to budgets and stick
to timescales and surveyors to be in a
good mood there can be problems but
fortunately now at this point in my
journey I've got full time builders that
work specifically in exclusively for me
I've got a full time project manager and
I think I've got a team and I think the
rules in the economy are up position
where I can now continue to pick up my
journey of buying and
mansik exciting times property 6 title
splitting this is pretty fun they call
this slice and dice and it's where you
buy a big property maybe an old house
and you convert it into two apartments
and minimum of two apartments and you
split the title and then sell each
apartment leaving you with a nice profit
an example of this would be if you
bought a big old derelict house for
seventy thousand pounds
you spent twenty thousand pounds doing
it up and you converted it into two
apartments which would be a very good
cost but when you've got full-time
builders and the right team that would
be possible so so far you've spent
ninety thousand pounds and you've now
got two apartments you then sell each
apartment separately for sixty-five
thousand pounds each bringing you in one
hundred and thirty thousand pounds
leaving you with a gross profit of forty
thousand pounds which is not a lot of
money but it's not bad if it's just one
deal in ten over a year's period
property seven seaside apartments now I
know I teach that property investing is
not about feelings it's all about
formulas but you know you can actually
make quite a lot of money from seaside
apartments there was seaside districts
some years ago and you could buy
apartments there for eighty ninety
thousand pounds but what happened was
the council regenerated the area and
suddenly suddenly you're talking 150,000
pounds minimum just to buy one-bedroom
apartment there are many seaside resorts
in the UK that haven't now been
regenerated so typically speaking you're
going to spend about a hundred fifty
thousand pounds minimum for a seaside
apartment however there are a couple of
areas in the UK whereby they haven't
regenerated the area's just yet
so what I've done is I've found an area
which is a seaside district where they
haven't
regenerated the area just yet but they
are about to so prices I believe I'm
gonna go up very very highly
however capital appreciation doesn't pay
the bells
so you can't rely on it so this
particular area that I found you can buy
a nice apartment for less than a hundred
thousand pounds and the rent that you
can demand is around about 750 to 800
pounds per month so even if they don't
regenerate the area like they are going
to and even if prices don't go up in the
area which they are going to you're
still going to be making a very healthy
return on investment from these type of
seaside apartments so I'm near buying a
seaside apartment hopefully for around
about eighty five thousand pounds
renting it out for 750 pounds where am I
going to do this exactly what's the area
I probably shouldn't tell you this this
is the thing people have been telling me
not to do because of competition but I
want to take where I live on my seaside
apartment and it is gonna be in
weston-super-mare property 8 will be a
HMO flip what I mean by HMO flip and how
will that work in the last 12 months I
have traded over a hundred and fifty HMO
properties to my students and investors
they've bought these HMOs for around
about 80 to 100 thousand pounds don't
spend about five thousand pounds you
know giving them looking pretty and then
furnished them as well and a lot of
these HMO properties now over 120 130
thousand pounds sometimes even more so
because they've done the heart and
they've put furniture and they put
tenants in suddenly the value of the
property has shot up you see if you're a
London investor and you see a HMO
opportunity but you're gonna have to do
it up you have to furnish it you have to
put tenants in it you might think oh
it's it's 80,000 pounds I'm not sure if
it will work but if someone comes and
does that for you and tests it out and
buys it and
and push the furniture and puts the
tenants in and it's generating 1500
pounds a month similarly as this busy
rich maybe London investor or Dubai
investor will say I'll pay 130 thousand
pounds for that no problem here's cash
so my strategy is going to be next year
and I have done this before but I'm
overdoing again this coming year is
going to be to buy a property very very
cheap maybe around about 60,000 pounds
hmm
to renovate it cheaply perhaps spending
ten thousand pounds plus furniture and
then to sell it as an up and running HMO
to a wealthy busy investor and make I
want to make a profit a gross profit of
a minimum of thirty thousand pounds
doing that which again is not bad for
just a little bit of work especially if
you enjoy it auction property auction
property is something that everybody
thinks is a great thing to do and lots
of people attempt however if you don't
know what you're doing you can fail
miserably so what I would suggest is
stay away from auctions unless you know
what you're doing
if you know what you're doing you can
make good money if you don't you can get
burned badly
[Music]
so that is my business plan next year
I'm sure I'm going to go into a lot more
than that I'm still gonna be finding
deals and packaging them and send them
on I'm still gonna be doing a little bit
of training as well so I hope that's
been useful and interesting if you want
to go and copy me go for it in fact if
you want to copy me and you want me to
help you copy me I will even do that so
just get along to one of the training
sessions at all or find out my mentoring
packages I'll happily help you to do the
exact same if you found this video
interesting and you want to see me doing
these you want to see me in the auction
room you want to see me at the seaside
negotiating behind the properties then
please do subscribe below and you'll get
to journey with me through the yeah also
I would love to know what your strategy
is going to be what's your business plan
what are you hoping to achieve what are
you hoping to buy next year so please do
comment below and let me know what your
strategy is and I will read with great
interest and cheer you on all the way
I'm I almost forgot number 10 number 10
property will be a service accommodation
property so I'll keep you posted on
Halligan odd and do get in touch come
along to one of my programs I'm very
happy to help in any way that I can
so subscribe right now and I'll see you
very soon god bless